do you experience loneliness while at
the top it's lonely at the top you've
heard that expression yeah yeah yeah
it's lonely at the top if so how did you
end you know actually not really and I
guess from my perspective I look at the
top being when I was in leadership
position walls platoon commander or
tasking a commander or the commander of
the training detachment was it lonely
the stuff not really man I had friends
and people that I hung out with and
people that I would trust to talk and to
have conversations with and so that
wasn't really a fact and then on top of
that I actually don't really mind being
alone it's not a big deal to me I don't
feel lonely when I'm by myself I'm fine
yeah somebody asked me the other day are
you an introvert or an extrovert yeah
and I was like mom probably both and
they're like no no but you have to be
one of course cuz right right they said
so yesterday yeah and and I said I said
well I don't care I literally don't care
like if I'm in a room with a bunch of
people okay if I'm in a room with by
myself don't care whatever bring it yeah
no big deal yeah I think the extrovert
if I'm not mistaken like like as the
need you know like he's there they're
like attracted to you know other people
being there yes so I guess that's I said
I'm like yeah that's fine whatever don't
care yeah alone so so yeah you know and
I always like I said I had friends that
I trust they didn't work weren't like
were good enough friends that they
weren't gonna be trying to get their own
gain out of being my friend you know
people that were friends with me before
I was in a leadership position and
people that remain friends after so yeah
yeah it's not not that big of a deal to
me you know luck I guess I'm lucky
because I mean it must be a thing
everyone says it yeah and I guess me
being in like I'll tell you what you do
you do you work I'll tell you this this
is what you when you when you're out
when you're at the top when you're a an
owner or you're the leader there's times
where you have to do things by yourself
yeah there's no doubt about that and if
you have a problem with that you you're
gonna have a problem being a leadership
system cuz there's things you have to do
is leader you have to lead from the
front you have to work harder you have
to do extra you you should be working
hard
than everyone else when you're in a
leadership position of an organization
no doubt about it and if you're not
working harder that's not good and if
you're if you're working harder there's
gonna be times when you're not with
anyone else and you have to be okay with
that and I'm perfectly okay with that
don't there yeah and that's actually
what when that's what that expression
means it's lonely at the top meaning
like you're at the top because you're
willing to in a general way of putting
it
behave or be a certain way that other
people either care right so you're not
gonna be able to relay from that
perspective you're definitely lonely at
the top
yeah there's no one that's gonna sit
there and do what I'm willing to do yeah
to be there yeah like where are you at I
don't know I haven't seen you but I'm
gonna promote myself but I'm gonna keep
getting after it right that's another
way yeah that's how people end up in
those positions yeah you don't end up in
those positions you don't get gifted
positions you don't just get end up I
just couldn't say never but I didn't it
sir yeah had to grind it out you know
keep grinding it out I think yeah you
know what think about this question I
said this did what you said doesn't
surprise me at all cuz II as a human
being I think we all kind of maybe
sometimes we do sometimes we don't admit
that it is good and nice to have like
someone there kind of supporting you in
this way and where where where you kind
of feel like Oh your feelings matter
kind of thing
yes I'm super soft but it's like kind of
deep down inside we're like let's say
you know how like you know look no no
listen so you know the idea that like
people just don't understand you know
that concept or people just don't get it
they don't understand or whatever yeah
so when you go to the top that feeling
is everyone everywhere the people just
don't understand this is the difference
I don't look at it people in a negative
light because they don't get it
I'm fine with it yeah like I recognize
that what I'm I recognize that I'm not
100% normal
yeah and I'm not yeah they're not I
don't look down right I actually I said
this word I just get interviewed oh I
got interviewed on a business insider by
and and he's like well do you always
keep your disciplines like no people get
all the SEAL Teams and they get fat and
they don't care anymore and it's like I
don't
don't care about that I'm stoked you
know that means they're stoked and
eating breakfast in bed and they're
hanging out with their kids it's all
good I don't I don't have a negative
opinion of them just like I don't have a
negative opinion of someone that
prioritizes things differently than me
it's fine yeah it's perfectly fine yeah
I get it
that that's my point and I'm okay yeah
I'm okay with that and I'm not looking
around going wow I wish I had more
people to hang out with it's only up
here that's exactly what lonely at the
top is though yeah yeah and there's it
there was when I was in my first co
platoon
we went to Guam we got there there was a
guy I don't even know who did it I don't
know where this I don't know who this
was but there was a seal that left like
a a surf ski you know what that is
no it's basically like a kayak that you
sit on top of anyways and there's a
little a little a little note to himself
it said the higher the fewer yeah
meaning like hey when you because he was
training hard for what I don't know who
it was just that the higher you the
higher the fewer so that's the same
thing yeah initially with it yeah make
sense
yeah man so like you know when you're in
the office working you know kids too
because that's a whole bullying thing as
people kids kids get the feeling that
being alone is bad yeah like being alone
is not a bad thing you should be
comfortable being alone yeah yeah and as
a normal human being it's key I think
for the most part okay being alone is
one thing but being alone with no choice
is another so like you if you you know
you're at the office cuz you just grind
all day you're at the tops lonely at the
top whatever you're in the office you're
working everyone else is out at you know
Thanksgiving whatever but you're working
cuz you got to work you're at the top
you're still there but you're working
you know kind of thing some people not
you some people will be like men you
know like I'm in this top position but I
give up like all these you definitely
give things you know and yeah exactly
right but again you say you're okay with
it I get it
of course yeah but if it gets to a point
where I'm not okay with it then I adjust
the balance there you go okay that's how
you deal in there but you got to be
playing the long-term game yeah not the
short-term gratification